wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
vielen dank dass dann hallo die hamas
haben uns für heute abend zum essen
eingeladen
ja natürlich als dankeschön für den
flohmarkt und das fahrrad bin ich auch
eingeladen
ja wieso nicht ich dachte du bist mir
zimmer befreundet ja schon was machst du
ich erkundige mich nur nach den regeln
in syrien ist schon etwas peinliches
passiert es reicht hier steht wenn sie
eine syrische familie begrüßen sollte
der mann der frau nicht die hand geben
das ist unüblich und gilt als unhöflich
außerdem wird sich nach dem befinden der
familie kündigt erkennen die familie
überhaupt nicht herr und hier steht es
gehört sich so nimmst das ganz schön
ernst hat das etwas mit dieser selber zu
tun
hallo ich bin ja ich bin ja meine frau
freut mich sehr vielen dank für die
einladung selber meine tochter
hallo ich bin micro freut mich sie
kennenzulernen
bitte setzen sie
wir können uns gerne duzen
wie geht es der familie familie familie
ich denke wir familie geht es gut und
deiner familie
ich denke ab
[Musik]